back new york governor andrew cuomo once
again facing heavy criticism from some
for new comments defending his handling
of the pandemic
take a look i put my head on the pillow
at night
saying i saved lives that's how i sleep
at night
and i know we have i know
this type of activity incompetent
ineffective government will cost lives
we've seen it from trump
he has cost lives and texas senator ted
cruz
clashing with the governor's brother on
cnn
was it a mistake when your brother
implemented a policy that nursing homes
had to accept covet positive patients
and endangered the lives
my brother was the first one to say but
there was a learning curve
and that mistakes were made and they
changed things as soon as they could
so greg is cuomo sleeping well because
he's referring to
the new york state new york city
experience
these are densely populated areas a lot
of international travelers coming in and
currently
a very low rate of coronavirus spread
well it's a low rate compared to the
past
they got hit super hard because of his
uh incompetence
he's as delusional as chris which proves
that he and his brother do
actually share the same single brain but
the one thing that
like i it drives me crazy is the ship
okay trump said um sent a massive
medical ship to the west side right and
it sat there
every day i drove by when i was coming
into the city unused
that's where they could have sent the
contagious folks and not go to the right
that's what it was for it was for it was
for
uh people with kovid and instead they
didn't want to use the ship
they used rest homes and killed all
those people and i'm trying to figure
out
it was huge a huge mistake and you
should own it but why i mean did you not
want to use the ship because trump sent
it to you
is that the reason i mean they've yet to
tell explain why the ship
was sent and not used if they sent those
however
many patients there there would be a
thousand still alive all right so degan
i was watching that cnn thing and i
thought what did the cnn audience get
out of that exchange what do you think
well you know what it's the people who
lost
loved ones in nursing homes in new york
and it's
thousands more than new york even admits
it's the people who deserve an
answer and andy cuomo won't give it to
them
this is so you know what i'm prone to
using a four-letter word and i've only
got
one for andy cuomo liar he actually
said that he denied that he said sending
covett patients directly from hospitals
never happened liar he is so pathetic
that cnn his brother's network
fact-checked his ass
and jake tapper bless him retweeted it
cuomo falsely claims new york nursing
homes never took in covet positive paces
you know what if andy cuomo was a
republican he would be indicted on
criminal charges for
killing all of those elderly people wow
you're in a rage
because you know what he it causes pain
for these people who lost loved ones
including janis dean
at every turn he is spitting on their
graves
wow okay dana a little bit of
controversy in new york about
uh the police enforcing mask rules but
i'm thinking to myself if you don't wear
a seat belt
they go they will penalize you it will
stop you so what's the difference with
the man well i think
like we we need the economy to get back
on track one of the best ways to get the
economy back on track is for people in
crowded situations
inside to be wearing a mask so and then
that concludes on a bus
or on a subway so i i i am for it and
and i think that that's it's a small
thing to do
to make sure not only that you're being
courteous to other people protecting
yourself
but also and that helps get everybody
back to work and
and money back into the city so that
they can pick up the trash for example
um the other thing i would say when it
comes to andrew cuomo
i'm sorry chris cuomo he somehow lets
ted cruz
back him into a corner where he has to
then defend
his brother and they used to have a rule
that you don't you can't
interview your brother right or you
can't like don't do family members and
like that's actually a pretty good rule
and i would maybe go back to that the
last thing i can have your dog on though
right dana well yes
absolutely i mean dogs are always
available i would even interview chris
cuomo's dog if he wanted to have him on
the show
um it's andy when andrew cuomo says he's
late you know
i get it he lays his head down he sleeps
well
having just got one question where's the
empathy
well you know again i think he may be
referring to the low rate but
jesse it got that that interview got
real personal with uh
chris cuomo saying that uh trump had
insulted
uh the senator senator cruz's wife
during the campaign and then the brother
so again i come back to the same
question why do it what did the audience
get out of that
well we got on the five well that's a
good answer
they doubled their audience tripled
their audience they tripled their
audience
i just want to be in the same room when
greg runs into chris cuomo one day
and i'm not going to break that fight up
i don't go to those clubs
i'll make this quick one yes yes i don't
understand how andrew cuomo can say he
did a good job
but president trump did a bad job when
president trump got
andrew cuomo everything he needed as
fast as he could
to help him out in new york